the public story of selfishness tells us
that we are all of us very guilty of the
behavior
we are apparently incurably addicted to
our own satisfactions and deserve to be
compared unfavorably to pretty much any
generation that ever walked the earth
it sounds compelling
self-flagellation usually does
but the reality may be somewhat
different
whatever the risks of excessive
self-absorption and inordinate pleasure
seeking the real danger for most people
is not that they too often ignore
society and other people in the name of
their own needs
it's precisely the opposite
that they constantly put aside
self-exploration and authentic inner
development for the whims of so-called
respectable opinion and socially
sanctioned duties and commitments
the chief problem is not that we're too
selfish we're poor versions of what we
might be because we're not selfish
enough
we spend our lives seeing people we have
nothing in common with working at jobs
that don't make sense to us
craving the approval of parental figures
who have other priorities
going to parties we fear sucking up to
colleagues we hate
going to films that bore us
parroting opinions we're suspicious of
taking holidays that we don't enjoy
and devoting ourselves to children who
end up either indifferent or plain
resentful about the care we've devoted
to them
finally in the last decade or so of life
we may try to live for ourselves
but by then it's almost always too late
our connections to our own tastes and
centers of pleasure and interest have
atrophied we've forgotten how to be
ambitious in our names we have fritted
ourselves away through millions of
demands we are alive
but we hardly exist any longer
we settle on golf
a priority while time allows is
therefore to acquire the skill of being
politely but energetically more selfish
we should from today
simply stop seeing people we dislike and
stop worrying to such an extent about
the opinions of strangers
we should focus on what feels meaningful
to us
we should ask ourselves what we will
wish we had done when we are on our
deathbeds and do it now
we should wonder what we would do next
if we had blanket permission
and go ahead and do it anyway we
probably know the life we should be
leading already
we have just been hoping and should stop
hoping
that someone or something would come
down from the sky and give us a
definitive seal of approval
we should acquire the art of being
difficult
of smiling less of saying no more often
and of leaving the room when we want to
the world won't fall apart if we neglect
some of our commitments
perhaps we can afford to forget
someone's birthday or let the house get
in a mess
fail to prepare a meal or suggest that a
grumpy relative make their own way back
from the station
we have grown quietly ill
or at least dull of spirit
through constant acts of self-sacrifice
we no longer have as many years ahead as
we once did
we have been good for an age
we have allowed our fear of boundless
egoism to blind us to the importance of
developing faith in ourselves
it may be time to take some baby steps
towards intelligent selfishness
for more from the school of life
you can subscribe to our channel and
take a look at our range of products on
our website